critics have called him brilliant a
master and the most important comedian
you're going to want to take a look at
this the show has been hailed as
incisive righteous and the smartest show
of them all
for nine Seasons tonight
bravely explored the greatest issues of
our time sex sex I'm horny who wants sex
if you are gonna a horse it should
definitely be this one with actual
information I'll call you right now that
woman ate her baby that is a that is a
fact that is a Disney fact
that's beautifully calibrated
avatars
and season 10 will be our biggest
boldest season ever we think because we
haven't made it yet so here's more of
the old stuff
it's been a busy week John yes it has oh
no no no no no no no no no no no no I'm
not going to be that kind of today show
host I told you because we're gonna get
weird tonight didn't I I put something
in your child no no no no no no you want
me to get in the car and sing I'm
America's naughtiest
oh
dead man tell no tellers off I did
this right now clap for me now it's
history Last Week Tonight with John
Oliver
[Music]